[Applaudissements]
au Sri Lanka les jeunes qui avaient fait
tomber le gouvernement en juillet était
encore dans les rues de la capitale
aujourd'hui il dénonce depuis 5 mois
l'inaction du gouvernement contre une
inflation galopante qui a atteint 70%
septembre les tablettes dans les
magasins sont vides le pays est
infaillite l'Indonésie est aussi
paralysée depuis le début de l'année il
y a eu plus de 600 manifestations contre
la flambée des prix de l'essence et des
aliments
plus bas des citoyens ont protesté
vendredi soir contre les coupures de
courants quotidiennes moins de 40% du
réseau électrique du pays est utilisé
faute de pétrole et de pièces pour
réparer les pannes et les banques manque
d'espèces
et on manque d'argent
en Équateur comme dans d'autres pays les
manifestations contre la vie chère ont
été violemment réprimés
nous marchions de façon pacifique de
cette étudiant jusqu'à ce que la police
nous attaque selon une compilation de la
BBC depuis le début de l'année 92 pays
ont connu des protestations contre la
hausse du coût de la vie la répression
de ces mouvements aurait fait au moins
80 morts dans une dizaine de pays
c'est la Sierra Leone qui enregistre le
plus lourd bilan 27 citoyens et si
policiers ont été tués en nous dans
plusieurs pays d'Afrique de l'Ouest le
prix du panier d'épicerie a plus que
doublé en moins d'un an c'est vraiment
une situation très difficile c'est
souvent démunis et ils ont pas la
possibilité d'avoir des programmes
d'aide relativement acceptés convenable
pour cette situation dramatique pour se
spécialiste des marchés du pétrole les
gouvernements ont peu de moyens pour
contrer le prix élevé du carburant je
l'ai ou subventionné le prix à la pompe
n'aide pas les plus démunis si nous les
pays industrialisés on maintient des
prix artificiellement bas la quantité
qui est disponible viendra plus
vers les pays industrialisés évidemment
ça va encore la situation davantage
précaire pour les pays pauvres selon
l'économiste
la seule au gouvernement peuvent faire
c'est une aide directe ou citoyenne qui
ont un revenu modeste les employeurs
aussi peuvent aider
la Belgique la France l'Espagne
l'Allemagne et l'Angleterre subissent la
pression de la rue la vie ça devenu
invivable les gens ils s'en sortent plus
à un moment donné on veut que le
gouvernement il pose des gestes forts il
faut des augmentations salariales en
Europe ce sont les syndicats qui
organisent les manifestations la
Commission européenne a réagi
aujourd'hui en annonçant que les pays
membres vont discuter jeudi d'une série
de mesures dont un blocage partiel du
prix à la pompe ici ce fil en gloire
Radio-Canada Montréal